-Guys, before we go on, I'd like
to take a moment to thank
some of our sponsors
for "Tonight Show."
They don't always get to fit in
the commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure
that we mention all of them.
So it's time for "Tonight Show
Sponsors." Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
-Stella Artois --
Sounds classy,
even when you're slurring it.
[ Applause ]
Turbotax, the official software
of waiting till April 14th.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Cold Stone Creamery --
Look, man, we're already
mashing up Snickers
on a marble slab for you.
Don't make us sing, too.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Aveeno Hand Lotion --
Have fun not being able to turn
a doorknob for an hour.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow.
Bass Pro Shops --
heaven on Earth for guys
who wear sunglasses
on the back of their heads.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sleep Number --
So you have trouble
sleeping with your spouse?
Yeah, let's pretend the mattress
is the problem.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yoplait -- you'll love us
if you're over 60 or under 5,
no in-between.
[ Laughter ]
Bloomingdale's -- hope you like
taking six escalators
to buy a belt.
[ Laughter ]
Hooters -- Wait, we haven't
been canceled yet?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Canada Dry --
Sprite for grandmas.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Dick's Sporting Goods --
Sure, we could have named it
literally anything else,
but here we are.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."